When wealthy people pass away,...
...they usually leave instructions for what to do with the money or property that they leave behind.
Often, the money and property go to their heirs.
However in some cases, rich pet owners leave their wealth to their pets after they die.
For example, there is a poodle named Toby.
When this poodle's owner passed away, she left Toby 15 million pounds,...
...about 25 million dollars.
Then there is Flossie, a yellow Lab mutt,...
...who is not only rich, but is also famous.
In 2001, Flossie made the headlines after she rescued her owner,...
...the actress Drew Barrymore and Drew's husband, from a house fire.
To thank Flossie, Drew gave her house to Flossie.
Of course, Drew repaired the fire damage first.
Now, Flossie is the owner of a beautiful three million-dollar home.
It may seem strange for a dog to own such an expensive home,...
...but Flossie is not the only dog like that.
Gunther IV, a German Shepherd, bought his home from Madonna...
...and paid over seven million dollars for the house.
However, this was no big deal for him...
...because Gunther IV has about 200 million dollars!
This makes him the richest dog in the world.
He inherited the money from his father, who was the heir to the fortune of a German countess.